we're here about 90 miles south of San
Francisco at the duros winery it's the
happens to be the oldest winery in
California which is a pretty big claim
to fame when did this winery officially
start the doors open in 1851 to do that
means you had to make wine so I'm
thinking 1847 about is when he actually
planted here before California was a
steak for gold was found yeah lots of
old history up here but sort of um you
don't hear a lot about it not only is
this the oldest winery in California but
I mean you guys are kind of famous
because you have the San Andreas Fault
exactly do you think that would you mind
letting us take a peek at that I love
for you see so right now we're sitting
on the San Andreas Fault your standard
on the continental shelf and I'm on the
Pacific plate we get runs all the time
you're probably a thousand plus a day
i'm thinking 1.2 1.8 these little guys
that humans don't really feel and I'm
going this way actually if you really
want to see what's going and you're kind
of going this way so we're being pulled
not much we can do about it it's just
what mom does here so do you feel safe
in here I feel very safe and yeah tell
you the truth the Navy they set up
satellites hear things like that right
there are recording or movement right
now okay see on top that white thing
yeah that's recording our movement from
the sound light right now you have any
sense over time how much things move
here well this is like 40 years okay so
all five of these trees used to be in
order it is straightened yep amazing yes
so tell me you a little bit more about
doing business with the San Andreas
Fault that isn't sort of effect of
farming the benefits of having rumblings
you know it brings up there's natural
springs here and water and and for us it
it brings up that water and allows it a
great to feed but that's where I see
what happens is is it comes up and feeds
that way which means we don't have to do
that right this is a pretty ass or
exciting for that part of it yeah I'm
not just the liner